radi a pas regardés malaga la question
c'est en fait est ce que le monde et
beaucoup étaient bien pires avants saia
ce qui aidera les gens étaient plus
raciste plus sexistes plus stigmatisant
plus tordus du coin c'est enfin puis
méchant moi je crois pas en fait je
pense que voilà je pense pas qu'on
voyant ces images on était on était plus
pourris qu'aujourd'hui on pensait on
penser - un mal je pense me devant ces
images là à l'époque maintenant
maintenant tu verrais des intentions
guen je pense que la tête quand même on
peut faire encore ce qu'on veut à la
télévision à dieu nous fait peut être un
petit strip tease nom fut vous voulez
alors mais je pense qu'on peut dire ce
qu'on veut d'ailleurs il ya eu juste à
regarder certaines télé réalité c'est
quand même très vulgaire par mois
franchement on peut dire ce qu'on veut
après ces sommes sur tf1 dès france 2
des chaînes hertziennes où il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de dymat on fait plus
attention on a quand même une liberté de
ton dans ce pays
au regard des deux pays comment ça se
passe on peut quand même dire ce qu'on
veut en france comme éthiquement oui oui
oui oui
est-ce qu'on veut dire ce qu'on veut je
suis d'accord aujourd'hui je trouve que
la parole est plus libre
il y avait quand même de la censure mais
faire ce qu'on veut non voilà c'est ça
c'est les autres qui aujourd'hui sont
absolument impossible non on peut plus
ça on peut plus faire sa patrie curé
qu'on voit tous les contractuels qui a
changé moi je me souviens quand j'étais
sa tf1 et sur les cinq j'avais un
contrat où j'avais la liberté éditoriale
de dire tout ce que je voulais sauce de
troubler l'ordre public c'est à dire
d'être à l'envers de la loi chose qui a
toujours respecté
mais depuis une dizaine d'années c'est
devenu complètement autre chose
c'est-à-dire que moi mes émissions il y
avait des gens qui étaient dans la salle
y avait deux personnes dans la salle qui
a appelé tout de suite la chaîne 10 ans
il a dit ça il a dit ça et on me disait
coupez coupez coupez coupez la
souviendra 12 ans tu sordide une
braguette
on est élu et moi c'est pour ça que j'ai
plus du tout envie de revenir dans ce
milieu là parce que j'ai envie d'être
libre
j'ai pas envie qu'on me coupe ça ne fait
plus rêver la télé aujourd'hui patrick
comment ça ne fait plus rêver la télé
aujourd'hui pas comme ça non non non on
est assez grand pour savoir les limites
qu'on ne doit pas tu sais quand j'étais
allé interviewer mitterrand il m'a dit
la censure ne doit pas ça serait la
pierre pour écraser la mouche me
rappelle très bien ce qui m'a dit ce
qu'il faut c'est vous trouviez vous même
les limites de votre bon goût et moi il
semble que j'ai au mieux j'ai essayé de
protéger il ya des mecs dans mes
émissions qui mendient redire s'agit non
tu
pas parce que c'est parce que tu vas
blesser quelqu'un etc tact et reconnu
qui a connu tous les présidents
ouais j'ai fait de l'auto sens je fais
n'était point sur ses terres en disant
ça tu peux pas venir parce que tu vas
blessés patrick tu étais proche de
jacques chirac
très proche je connais c'est bien
françois hollande aussi parce que tu
essaies de brive les chirac mais jacques
sont battus c'est quand chirac est mort
si une certaine france qui est mort il
ya cette france-là chirac aujourd'hui il
y en prendrez plein la gueule parce que
les blagues un peu la bière à la main le
machin etc